now Ukraine's President zielinski says
that his country's war with Russia will
not be over until his forces have
retaken Crimea Ukrainian troops are
currently engaged in that
counter-offensive to try to win back
territory from Russian forces with the
latest on the situation on the ground
we're joined now by the former British
Army intelligence and security officer
Philip Ingram and it
pretty easy Phillips take your eyes off
Ukraine sometimes what what is going on
at the moment it is well we're day 495
of Vladimir Putin's 10-day special
military operation and I think we're
probably 495 days further away from
Crimea being on on the cards to take
ukrainians are they've continued the
initiative in the counter offense of
they're attacking to the north and south
of buckmut and making some successes
your 500 meters a kilometer in it took
the Russians seven uh sorry 18 months to
get seven kilometers and capture the
town itself they're attacking down
through the Donetsk zaparizia oblas
border just south of Donetsk and they're
attacking a main effort attack um done
in through zaparizio down to top Mac or
seems to be main effort and that's
trying to split that land bridge that
there is coming up from Crimea up into
Russia right and the ukrainians are
trying to sort of keep the Russians
occupied elsewhere as well you were
talking about this bridge down here
what's going on they are and across the
board we've got about 600 kilometers of
Frontline in the antonovsky bridge which
we've got a picture of
um the uh the ukrainians put a small
Special Forces element across and held a
bridge head there they're never going to
get tanks or armored vehicles across
that but that's keeping the Russians
guessing as to what's going on and
keeping their Reserve forces split and
therefore they can't concentrate the
reserves to try and counter any
Ukrainian push through when it happens
it's still early days ukrainians got the
initiative it's still working but it's
slower than expected well that was to be
my next question I mean it was a much
vaunted much expected counter-offensive
it does seem to be going uh pretty
slowly or cautiously cautiously is the
way I put it and I think we're lured
into false sense of security because of
the success and heart cave and Harrison
last year which were very rapid indeed
this is different the Russians have had
nine months to build very very complex
interlinked and layers of defenses with
mines and anti-tank ditches and
anti-tank traps and all the rest of it
all covered by indirect Fire by
anti-tank missiles and from the back
with helicopter on their Air Forces so
it's a very different different game and
the ukrainians have to probe very
carefully and plunge through when
they're ready right and the attempted
Mutiny
um uh what about I mean what's happening
where is pregosia do we know yeah
Belarus that's the six million dollar
question we have to remember he was
Putin Chef they're clearly not very good
looking at Vladimir Putin's um uh
expression but no I understand that the
Kremlin have withdrawn all of his
contracts so he's losing his money um
from the military his contract was
chefing to not just the Kremlin but
providing all of the food for the
Russian military that's gone and
progressions expected or we believe he's
he's in
um Belarus at the moment but um he's
gone quiet as have those who were
potentially been questioned as as
potential supporters from them there
have been some reports that he's
starting to build up his Wagner group
inside Belarus now
um unconfirmed reports today of him
going around some of the Belarusian
prisons but that could be part of
information operations just trying to do
things but there are also reports of him
building a camp and I think we've got a
picture of a a camp that has been
associated with the Wagner group just
inside Belarus so we never we We Know
It's associated with the Wagner group do
we think believe it is a number of
different intelligence organizations an
open source intelligence organizations
have suggested it is but yeah there's so
much disinformation around that will
help the ukrainians help the Russians
and it's very difficult um to know
what's real fact right and just finally
I mean the ukrainians are sort of
prepared I guess for a sort of an attack
from the yeah which was one of the
things being mooted I mean it's
interesting you have precaution is
preparing a military force that's in
there he's still working with Vladimir
Putin if he tries to attack down into
Ukraine
um we warn the Russians that um sir
warned the ukrainians that the Russians
were attacking back in February we'll be
watching this very closely and if he
does prepare for us to go in the
ukrainians will get plenty of notice and
they will have prepared and they've
rehearsed their defenses to stop them
coming through okay Philip uh
interesting stuff thanks very much
indeed